- Welcome back, y'all. Keenan
Thompson is here with us.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Our next guest is a Grammy-winning artist
who is one of dancehall
and reggae's most prolific
and successful musicians ever.
His latest single is called "Dem Time Deh"
featuring Manuel Turizo.
Listen now wherever you get your music,
everybody say hello to Sean Paul.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Hello, hello. I like all your bling.
- Thank you.
- Yes.
- Crazy stuff.
- You're like,
"I work hard for this."
(Sean laughs)
Y'all met, right?
You know each other?
- Yeah, yeah, just now.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, I was
on "Saturday Night Live" a while back.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- I don't know
if you were there that day, but-
- I was there that day, but we
didn't get a chance to meet.
We don't get a chance to meet every-
- I know.
- Single time.
But yeah, no, I've been a
big fan for a long time.
- Salute, man. Same, same.
- So wait, your stage
name is Sean da Paul.
What is that from?
- Sean Paul is my name.
My name is Sean-Paul.
But there's a famous
cricketer in the Caribbean,
and his name is Chanderpaul,
that's his last name.
And it sounded so much like my own.
Yeah, there he is.
- Yeah.
- And he's from Guyana.
And a lot of people came at me
because I first said he's from Trinidad,
and I made a mistake, excuse me.
But, you know, it was a friend
of mine who was freestyling,
and I was going next on the
mic, like, doing freestyling.
And he was like, "Yo, Sean da Paul."
And everybody laughed and they were like,
"Yo, that's the cricketer's name."
But it kind of stuck on me as
a nickname around the studio.
And I started to say it in songs and-
- I love that.
- Yeah (laughs).
- I found this incredible too.
So you grew up around
a lot of country music.
- Jamaica, we love all
kind of different music.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And so, yeah, we have a lot of people
who are fans of country music.
I think it reminds us of reggae.
It tells a story. It's that type of music.
So yeah, Kenny Rogers and Willie Nelson.
- Kenny Rogers.
- I love Willie Nelson, man.
- I love this.
(audience applauding)
- I knew Willie Nelson
was coming up there.
- Willie Nelson-
(Sean da Paul laughs)
- I needed to check.
- Was coming in there. Yeah.
- He's a Jamaican.
- Yeah, but he-
- I think he's Jamaican.
- He's a lifestyle.
(Sean chuckles)
Yeah (chuckles).
- He's honorary Jamaican.
- That's right. Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Or we're honorary
listeners to his music.
- Right. Brilliant.
- But yeah-
- On top of it,
he smokes a lot of weed.
- Yeah.
- Yeah (laughs).
- I went on his bus once and I was like...
♪ Hey ♪
And then I walked off a different human.
(Sean chuckles)
(Kelly chuckles)
- We have similar, you know,
what we call-
- Loves and interests?
- Interests.
- Yes.
Yeah. Love languages if you will.
Yes.
- For sure.
- So wait, so your new single
is called "Dem Time Deh."
- You got it right.
- That's the music? Okay.
"Dem Time Deh."
- Yes, you're right.
- Yeah. What does that mean?
- It means back in the day. Dem time deh.
Those times there.
So basically, a lot of people
kind of remember my career
from about 20 years ago,
and Manuel, he's a lot younger than me.
And he was like, "Yo, back
in those days was awesome,
and I wanna do a song like that with you."
And he came to the studio
and he started writing,
and he's like, "What do
you want to call it?"
And I said, "Since it's so
reminiscent of dem time deh,
let's call it "Dem Time Deh," he loved it.
I've been trying to bridge the gap
between reggaeton and dancehall
music or reggae music,
because we're such close in proximity
to Puerto Rico and
Dominican Republic, Cuba,
but we don't speak the language.
And so, we do speak music though.
- Yeah, connection, man.
Music is magical like that.
- For sure.
- I love when you go to a show
and you look around,
that's my favorite part
of getting on stage.
And I look at the audience and I'm like,
"Where would all of us
be in the same room?"
You know what I'm saying?
Other than this moment.
You just happen to like these songs,
you happen to like this vibe.
I love that about music.
That never gets old.
- Music gets us together.
It gets us through some crazy times.
My mom was telling me a story
about one of your songs,
and she was like,
she was doing some very
mundane stuff one day,
sweeping floors and that kind of stuff.
And a lot of people was helping her out,
and she started singing
"A Moment Like This."
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, 'cause it was kind of funny,
'cause nobody wants to wait-
- A moment. Yeah.
- Their whole life to do that.
Right?
(audience laughing)
- Your mom is funny.
(Sean chuckling)
- So she said, "I must big you up,"
and it helped everybody get through it.
They all was singing it
and motivated them to-
- Well, she has-
- Finish the job
they were doing.
- Incredible taste, Sean.
- (laughs) Yeah, she does.
(audience laughing)
- That's right.
- Yes.
- She does.
- She has incredible taste.
(Kelly laughs)
- Thank you.
- All right, we've got a
performance of the new single,
"Dem Time Deh," from Sean
Paul featuring Manuel Turizo
coming up later.
You can download the song now
wherever you get your music.